اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
نستضيف فيها دائما المحلل العسكري اللواء
فائز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اهلا بك معنا قبل ان نتحدث للواء فائز
الدويري نذهب الى سلام خضر التي تطلعنا
على الخريطه التفاعليه على ابرز التطورات
الميدانيه سلام شكرا عبد السلام القتال في
قطاع غزه صعب ومعقد هكذا وصفت اليوم قوات
الاحتلال المعارك الدائره في اكثر من نقطه
في ق قطاع غزه سنبدا من ال جنوب القطاع
الذي يشهد معارك مستمره وايضا متصاعده من
حيث الكثافه وايضا التوسع الجغرافي مدينه
خانيونس لا تزال المركز الاول لهذا القتال
القوات الاسرائيليه لم تستطع حتى الان
التوغل داخل المدينه لمسافات طويله تتمركز
عند نقطه نقطه البلديه وفيها مبنى ضخم
بحسب المعلومات حولت هذا المبنى القوات
الاسرائيليه الى غرفه عمليات او الى مقر
مبدئي لها في المكان بالتزامن مع ذلك
استعانت اليوم بالمقاتلات لاستهداف اكثر
من موقع داخل مدينه خانيونس وهي
استراتيجيه وهو تكتيك تستخدمه القوات
المتوغلة
س هيلا بالتحديد بعض النقاط تراجعت عنها
وتمركزت بعيدا قليلا عن مداخل هذه الاماكن
الابرز هو ما اعلنه اليوم الجيش
الاسرائيلي تحدث عن ان وحده مشتركه او
مجموعه مشتركه من ثلاثه الويه الويه
النخبه والويه المشاه ولواء الهندسه
اكتشفوا نفقا في مكان ما في جنوب القطاع
في خانيونس في جنوب قطاع غزه لم يحددوا
بالضبط المكان الذي وجد فيه تحدثوا عن انه
ممتد وطويل ومتشعب وانهم وجدوا فيه اثار
تدل على امكانيه ان يكونوا الاسرى او
المحتجزين قد تواجدوا فيه في مره من او في
احد ايام هذه الحرب منذ بدئها عند السابع
في السابع من اكتوبر وقالت انها فجرت هذا
النفق دون اعطاء معلومات اضافيه كان
بطبيعه الحال هناك
استهدافات مباشره للقوات الاسرائيليه
استهدفت القسام تجمعا للجنود وا استهدفت
ايضا مقرا تستخدمه لاداره المعركه
الميدانيه
في المنطقه الوسطى يمكن ان نقول بان هناك
نوع من الجمود النسبي او المحدود في
العمليات القتاليه هذا القوس الصيرات
البريج المغازي لا يزال محور القتال
الاساسي وكان هناك محاولات توغل من
الزوايده وايضا محاولات توغل من المصدر في
جنوب البريج الجمود هذا قد يساعد القسام
وكتائب المقاومه على شن المزيد من الهجمات
تعتبر ان ان تكون الجيوش جامده في مكانها
متمركزه في مكانها ستتعرض بالطبع لمزيد من
العمليات وربما قد يخبر هذا عن وجود
اضطراب في سير العمليه في المنطقه الوسطى
التي بدات قبل نحو ثلاثه اسابيع وهذه هي
النقطه الاساسيه التي تنتقد عليها قوات
الاحتلال بانها ايه لم تتمكن من تطويع
الانتشار الميداني بسرعه كافيه لتلائم
طبيعه المعركه التي تخوضها في قطاع غزه
وهي معركه غير تقليديه تقاتل مجموعه مسلحه
حركه مقاومه في الشمال الذي قال امس الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان حركه حماس الجراح العسكري
لم يعد لديها وجود شهدت اليوم بعض القتال
في مناطق متفرقه لا سما في الدرج والتفاح
ولكن الاهم اليوم ان كتائب الق قسام اطلقت
دفعه صواريخ الى داخل المناطق الاسرائيليه
بشكل سريع هذه التطورات سنسمع منك ومع
اللواء الدويري التحليل نعم وسنتابع من
خان يونس شكرا جزيلا لك سلام خضر الاعين
تترقب ما الذي يحدث تحديدا الجانب
الاسرائيلي يركز هذه الايام عن الانفاق
ولاحظنا بالامس كيف انه تم نشر فيديو
لاستدراج مجموعه الى فوات نفق ثم تفجيره
لكن الجانب الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن عديد
الانفاق التي تمت تم كشفها والعشرات منها
تم تفجيره ما دلاله ذلك برايك يعني هو في
الواقع هناك مجموعه من المشكلات التي
تواجهها قوات
الاحتلال في عجاله المشكله الرئيسيه التي
نتج عنها كل هذا الاضطراب والارتباك في
اداره المعركه عدم توفر المعلومه الدقيقه
عن الجانب الاخر غياب
المعلومه فرض على جيش الاحتلال ان يقاتل
كل يوم
بيوم
هو المهاجم هو صاحب المباداه هو صاحب
العمل الاول وبالتالي المهاجم هو الذي
يبدا الحدث والمدافع هو الذي يتعامل مع
الحدث لا في ظل غياب المعلومه لم يعد
المبادر هو يخطط كل يوم بناء على نتائج
المعركه في اليوم السابق لهذا السبب نجد
حاله الارتباك وحاله الجمود الت تحدثت
عنها الان ناتي ل المعضله اخرى معضله
الانفاق حتى هذه اللحظه خاصه في المناطق
الوسطى والجنوبيه شبكه الانفاق يبدو معقده
اكثر مما كانت في الشمال بسبب طبيعات
الارض اتساع الارض وال قياسا مع الشمال
يضاف الى ذلك ال طبيعه ال الجغرافيا
والديموغرافيا عد المباني موزعه مسافات
بينيه زاد عدد الفتحات الانفاق فبالتالي
زادت الاصابات وزادت درجه او اعداد
الكمائن يضاف الى ذلك انه تم اكتشاف بعض
الانفاق وعلى سبيل المثال النفق الذي
اشارت له في هذا اليوم هو نعم متشعب وطويل
لكن السؤال لماذا تم
تدميره لو كان هذا النفق
كقراء يفضي الى شبكه الانفاق الهجوميه
الحقيقيه لا يمكن
تدميره لانه فقد الاثر والدليل الذي يوصله
الى ما بعد اذا هو دخل في هذا النفق كان
متعرجا لديه تشعبات وتفرعات ولكنه في
النهايه كان نفقا مغلقا لهذا السبب قام
بتدميره اذا
ستبقى شبكه الانفاق عقده رئيسيه امامه كما
هي غياب المعلومه والحصول على المعلومه في
الوقت المناسب خصوصا انه يتم استخدام بعض
الانفاق ككما كما شاهدنا وهنا هرسي اليفي
عندما يقول بان المعركه معقده هذا تقييم
بناء على زياره ميدانيه في العلم العسكري
عندما يكون رئيس الاركان رئيس اكبر كان في
في في الجيش يقول المعركه معقده بعد تقييم
ميداني ما الذي يعنيه ذلك هو يحاول ان
اي يوضح بان الجيش يبذل اقصى ما لديه من
قدره لتحقيق انجازات لكن يواجه معضلات لا
يستطيع التغلب عليها بسهوله لهذا السبب
انا قلت لك في البدايه وهو ينسجم مع ما
قاله ان المعركه تدار كل يوم بيومه انت
الان في عمليه التعرض حتى لو كنت في
المناطق المبنيه لديك اهداف هذه الاهداف
هي في معظمها اي موضعه جغرافيا حتى داخل
المدن يجب قد يكون نقطه قد يكون تجمع قد
يكون خطوط وبالتالي ساحدث اهدافي واجز
الاهداف الى اهداف مرحله مرحله اولى ثانيه
ثالثه لكن في حال الفشل في الحصول على
معلومه وعدم معرفته اين العدو كيف سيقاتل
العدو من اين يخرج العدو
هنا يكون الحذر مبالغ فيه مما يفضي الى
حاله من الجمود وعن الحذر ايضا نتحدث
عندما تقول الاحصائيات بان قتل الجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه الحرب 26% منهم من
الضباط هل على جيش الاحتلال ايضا ان ينظر
لهذه الارقام بطريقه مختلفه وان يخفف هذه
الاعداد يعني هو الان هذه هذا هو الاختبار
الحقيقي لكفاءه الضابط في في المستويات
الدنيا من مستوى دون قائد الكتيبه حتى
مستوى قائد الفصيل وكفاءه صف الضباط او
ضباط الصف هو يعاني من مشكله في في حقيقيه
و هناك مثل ضربته واستشهدت به اكثر من مره
اقول في الكمين الذي نفذ على ثلاثه
مراحل المرحله الاولى كان قائد فصيل
المرحله الثانيه دفع بقائد سريه المرحله
الثالثه دفع بقائد كتيبه يشرف على عمليه
تخليص تخليص المجموعه هذا على ماذا يدل
يدل ان مستوى الكفاءه متدني المهاره
متدنيه يبدو حتى الثقه بالنفس متدنيه لهذا
السبب نجد الضباط يقوموا بادوار صف الضباط
مما يجعلهم عدد كبير في الخطوط الاماميه
ويؤدي الى وقوع الخسائر الكبيره منطقه
الوسط ذكرت سلام بانها منطقه يبدو ان هناك
مراوح في العمليات الى ماذا يرجع ذلك هذه
المنطقه خضعت عده تغييرات من حيث هيكليه
القوات هذه في بدايه انطلاق العمليه
العسكريه وضعت تحت سيطره وا والسيطره
واداره المعركه للفرقه المدرعه 36 سحبت
بعد اخفاقات عديده خاصه في البريج كانت
الزاويه الاساسيه
للعمل تم سحب الفرقه 39 ولا يعني اخراج كل
قواتها سحبت اداره المعركه من الفرقه 36
وتم ايكال الى الفرقه الميكانيكيه 99
والان اعيد تجميع القوه بحيث اصبح فيها
اربع الويه لواي نخبه ولوا اي دروع
وبالتالي الان تم مزج هذه الالويه مره
اخرى لتتلاءم مع طبيعه المعركه فاصبح عندك
لواء ممزوج مختلط من المشاء من قوات
النخبه والدروع لكل لواء وحاول اخراج
مجموعه قتال لتعمل احاطه الى غرب الزوايده
وجنوب الزوايده لفصل الزوايده والمغازي عن
دير البلح جيش الاحتلال يكثف عملياته عبر
الطائرات المسيره وتم اسقاط عدد منها هل
تعتقد بان هذه الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه لجيش
الاحتلال ناجحه لا الان هذه كانت نتيجه
اخفاقات سابقه في الفتره الاخيره بدا
الاعتماد على الطائرات المسيره بتركيز
كبير جدا واذا عدنا خلال الايام الماضيه
هناك حديث عن اسقاط عدد منها شبه يومي في
بعض الايام وصلت الى
اربعه الان
لماذا قلت لك طبيعه المعركه اصبحت مختلفه
عنها في داخل مدينه غزه مدينه غزه عباره
عن كتله من المباني ال يخرج المقاتل من
النفق مباشره الى داخل مبنى مهدم ويستهدف
هنا لا يخرج من فتحه النفق يجبر على
الحركه هذه الطائرات تعمل تنقل صور مباشره
الى القادي الميد
فتم تكثيفها من اجل حل مشكله المعلومه
التي قلت في بدايه حديثي انها المعضله
الكادا بالنسبه لجيش الاحتلال شكرا جزيلا
لك اللواء فائز الدويري على كل ما تفضلت
به شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه
عوده الان الى غرفه
الاخبار